felice di essere tornato nella mia
puglia per raccontarvi che
contrariamente allo slogan della mia
associazione no profit che sui for
change la fotografia non cambia il mondo
il mondo lo cambiano evidentemente le
persone lo cambiano i dettagli lo
cambiano le piccole piccolissime storie
e questa è una cosa che ho imparato col
tempo grazie anche alla fotografia e
grazie anche sul for change
molto spesso però le queste storie sono
sottovalutate sono dimenticate sono
ignorate perché non sono considerate
remunerative dall'informazione
tradizionale di informazione mainstream
e non venendo considerate remunerative
non vengono raccontate e se non vengono
raccontate non possono e non riescono a
dispiegare con gli effetti e quelle
dinamiche di emulazione anche creativa
che porta poi a interconnettere magari
anche attraverso i social network queste
piccole storie e far diventare grandi e
grandissime e alla fine cambiare dei
piccoli mondi ed è così che sta facendo
quello che era era nato come un mio
piccolo blog meno di tre anni fa dove
anni e mezzo fa e unendo mescolando in
maniera forse un po azzardata all'inizio
capacità impegno sociale creatività e
voglia di mettersi in gioco di scendere
prestare a raccontare storie questo
piccolo questo piccolo blog è diventato
improvvisamente un'associazione no
profit italiana con adesso gruppi di
volontari in tutto il mondo
dopodiché ha fatto un ulteriore salto di
qualità recentemente ed è diventato una
sorta mi è sfuggita di mano sorta una
sorta di movimento movimento di racconta
storie al servizio gratuito di coloro
che non se lo possono permettere di
quello che non si possono permettere un
fotografo un videomaker un musicista
qualcuno che li racconta in qualche
maniera qualcuno che lasci una traccia
del loro agire del loro cambiare il
mondo
e poiché come vi ho detto sono convinto
è fermamente convinto che si possa ci
possa essere un racconto dei dettagli
delle persone dalle storie che cambiano
il mondo
unità un concetto di una fotografia che
lascia qualcosa di reale un contributo
reale nella realtà che viene raccontata
dalle storie che vengono raccontate
vi racconto 3 dettagli e tre fotografie
vi mostrate le fotografie anzi non ve le
mostre oggi provo per la prima volta un
esperimento
vi chiedo un po di immaginazione
cercando di ridisegnare di fotografare
con la vostra mente quello che vi
racconterò sono tre storie la prima è
una fotografia
immaginate la verticale in bianco e nero
nella mia fotografia di qualche giorno
fa c'è un giovane uomo dalla pelle
leggermente olivastra mezzo busto è
evidentemente quasi appoggiata una
colonna di marmo bianco lo sfondo
leggermente sfocato probabilmente chi si
intende di fotografia potrei immaginare
un f 456 una focale un diaframma
abbastanza aperto che lascia un po
sfocato lo sfondo ma si capisce che ci
si trova in una chiesa quest'uomo
indossa un giubbotto di pelle nera una
camicia nera con delle linee verticali
bianche e ha al collo un bel c'è scritto
staff ha un po di ho un po di rughe
intorno agli occhi avrà un'età tra i 35
38 40 anni mi guarda con uno sguardo
abbastanza sereno leggermente sorridente
gli zigomi leggermente alzati lo sguardo
è leggermente triste malinconico ma
sostanzialmente sereno come si chiama
kaiser è un rifugiato iracheno roma e
anzi era anzi è un giornalista era un
giornalista piuttosto conosciuto in
pakistan chiedo scusa iracheno il
pakistan conosciuto è diventato anche
piuttosto famoso soprattutto all'estero
perché lui è cattolico e appartiene alla
quella minoranza del 3 per cento di
cristiani anzi in pakistan errato andava
in giro per il pakistan da raccontare la
persecuzione da parte dei talebani da
parte della del regime
pachistano ne danno ai danni della
comunità cristiana è dovuto scappare via
ricevuto delle minacce di morte è
scappato solamente da pochi mesi ha
avuto la ricongiunzione con con la
famiglia con la moglie con i figli tutta
la famiglia in pakistan ha subito
l'impatto della della persecuzione
lui adesso fa il sagrestano nella chiesa
di sant'ignazio a roma non lo conosceva
nessuno
l'ho scoperto per caso l'ho raccontato
il mazzetto sono felice perché sono
andato via con me io non sono felice
perché sono andato via ma sono su felice
perché sono ancora vivo con la mia
famiglia ma non faccio più giornalista
lui adesso scriverà sul for change
ricomincerà piano piano a mettersi in
gioco e mi ha ricongiunto sull'idea che
ci sono tante storie che non conosciamo
per noi rifugiati sono rifugiate basta
quando arrivano in italia smettono di
essere rifugiati sono qualche altra cosa
e erano altre cose magari erano anche
creativi prima storia la seconda
fotografia e sempre in verticale ma
questa volta colori c'è quello che
sembra un ragazzo un giovane uomo
accovacciato per terra appoggiato con la
schiena lui dei profilo anche di tre
quarti appoggiata una parete di legno
marrone scuro indossa delle ciabatte
alla con ragione piuttosto scura ha un
problema evidente al labbro nel profilo
che mostrano dentatura piuttosto
importante un naso importante
lo sguardo è chinato verso il basso
verso il suo piede davanti al quale c'è
una gallina che sta beccando nel fango e
la si capisce che lui seduto su una
pozzanghera a terra
sullo sfondo c'è un po di verde
abbastanza sfocato e si capisce che
siamo in un contesto a metà strada fra
il dentro e il fuori quindi è sulla
soglia probabilmente di una stanza della
camera di una casa di un garage di
qualche cosa sullo sfondo c'è una rete
come un pollaio una rete verticale
frontale ma anche una rete
sopra la testa sembra una gabbia questo
ragazzo si chiama mondo e il suo mondo è
confinata in una gabbia vive tuttora in
chapas nelle montagne sperdute del dl
chapas ea un problema psicologico soffre
di disturbi della personalità che i
genitori in famiglia poverissima come
tutto il resto del chapas zona nella
quale il governo messicano non fornisce
alcuna assistenza sanitaria né gratuito
anni a pagamento non esiste proprio
assistenza sanitaria non capendo i
disturbi del figlio temendo le continue
e non sopportando più le continue fughe
del figlio
l'hanno chiuso in una gabbia lo fanno
dire in una gabbia ma non per cattiveria
per ignoranza non sanno che è malato non
sanno neanche cosa sia la malattia
mentale stanno semplicemente che così è
per contrastarla non ha chiuso in una
gabbia
questa storia è stata raccontata un team
di nostre fotografa i fotografi e
giovanissimi che hanno attraversato il
messico sono messicani sui facendo in
messico city per raccontarla questa
storia ha fatto il giro di internet è
arrivata in italia è ritornato in
messico e qualche giorno fa un famoso
messico per il famoso medico messicano
ha mandato un'email dicendo io ho capito
pensa di aver capito la malattia di
questo ragazzo si è offerto volontario e
andrea curare gratuitamente questo
ragazzo grazie una piccola piccolissima
storia un piccolo dettaglio
l'ultima storia un'immagine molto forte
questa vi chiedo anche un ulteriore
sforzo di immaginazione una forma una
fotografia a questo punto questa volta
orizzontale in bianco e nero molto forte
molto contrastato
l'ambientazione evidentemente è un
probabilmente un bagno perché c'è una
parete sullo sfondo piastrellata c'è un
giovane uomo che è un fotografo che
impugna con la mano sinistra la macchina
fotografica davanti alla sua faccia
quindi è un autoritratto allo specchio
si capisce che davanti a uno specchio il
suo braccio sinistro che impugna la
macchina ea tutto tatuato davanti a lui
c'è una giovane donna che chiude con una
mano con la mano destra un asciugamano
intorno alle spalle guarda fissa lo
schermo ai capelli molto corti ha dei
bellissimi occhi abbastanza sorridente
non è del tutto serena ma una bella
ragazza demetra te molto femminile
l'altra mano del fotografo di questo
ragazzo anche co anche questo braccio
abbastanza tatuato impugna un rasoio
elettrico sta tagliando i capelli a
questa ragazza
approfondendo l'immagine sullo sfondo
c'è un'asta con delle flebo
probabilmente non è più un bagno privato
probabilmente il bagno a una stanza di
ospedale confermata da alcuni flaconi di
di medicine nella zona
lei si chiama jennifer lui si chiama
angelo angelo merendino un mese dopo il
viaggio di nozze questi ragazzi hanno
scoperto la malattia di genere un cancro
al seno che l'ha portata va dopo una
lunga malattia a morire di tumore e lei
ha chiesto al marito di raccontare la
sua storia passo passo le ha raccontate
con una serie di foto pare tamente
pietose tutti passati dalla malattia ma
in realtà si tratta di una grandissima
storia d'amore ne ha fatto una una
battaglia personale fino a quel momento
angelo care in italia qualche giorno fa
ed è ritornata a new york e ieri mattina
mi ha detto io fino a quel momento non
aveva mai fatto niente la mia vita ero
un noto batterista di una nota band punk
rock americana e girava per gli stati
uniti dopo la malattia della moglie con
questo uso della fotografia straziante
ma grande segno d'amore ha dedicato
tutta la sua vita a raccontare
fotograficamente questo fenomeno e ha
creato una sua associazione di fund
raising e no profit per dare assistenza
sanitaria alle famiglie che soffrono che
combattono battaglie che non si scelgono
noi siamo al servizio di queste piccole
storie e se è vero che
le storie sono nei dettagli
ecco
potete avanzare per piacere nel side non
funziona è la cosiddetta legge di murphy
adesso la ricarichiamo nel frattempo
mette si ricarica la presentazione di
conferma che i nostri volontari sono in
giro per il mondo sono al servizio
gratuito che alle tante piccolissime
storie
siamo dei racconta storie facciamo
solamente a questo dalla mattina seria
noi siamo al servizio di queste storie
dimenticate sottovalutate ignorate
qualcuno un grande fotografo ha detto
che i ricchi hanno i loro fotografi
noi siamo servizi tutti gli altri perché
ci sono storie che devono essere
raccontata grazie